uh breaking news from the energy
regulator off gem on the new price cap
our business correspondent with Godfrey
is here with us hi tell us more yeah so
off gem it's the energy regulator it
caps the amount that energy companies
can charge customers for each unit of
electricity and gas the announcement
that it made today would normally mean
that your typical household based on
typical usage would see that energy
bills from January go up to 4 279 pounds
a year wow that's a terrifying number
but before I cause any alarm this
doesn't mean that people's bills will be
going up by that March or too that much
and that's because the government has
stepped in you may have heard of the
energy price guarantee but it's
effectively promised to cap People's
Energy bills that typical household that
we like talking about at 2 500 pounds up
until April and then from April it will
cap it at 3 000 pounds for another year
so you may be thinking well if I don't
have to pay it it doesn't affect me but
someone does have to pick up the bill
and that that figure that has to pick up
the bill it's the government so the
difference between the government's cap
at 2500 and off gems cap is being born
the cost is being born effectively by
the taxpayer and it's a huge amount of
money we don't know exactly how much
this intervention is going to cost
because we don't know what wholesale
Energy prices are but some forecasters
are saying that this could cost us in
the region of about 38 billion pounds
over 18 months was that factored in well
it's Diamond it was factored in yes it
was factored in but it's changing all
the time because wholesale prices are
changing constantly and to put that in
context furlough cost us a hundred and
billion 100 billion pounds over 18
months so it's a massive massive
intervention and uh critically it's
untargeted so whether you're rich or
poor everyone's getting support and this
is something economists have also warned
about because they fear that by giving
people this cash it could actually fuel
inflation at a time when we know
inflation is running at a 41 year high
and that could force the bank of England
to put up interest rates so the costs of
all of this will indirectly be borne by
all of us